It's one of the cool things about travel,
right?
You broaden your perspective and your
understanding of what it means to be a
person. Go to these different
environments and yourself too. Yeah, yeah.
There are different and they're
different foods or different art.
There are different architecture and he
goes, oh, this is also possible to, yes,
people can live like this.
Yes.
And do you even begin to see why
they live like that? You know,
like you initially you go to Greece
and you have resin flavored wine,
you have it at Siena and a,
you wondering why would these crazy
Greeks put pine resin in there ruining
perfectly good white wine. And then
after awhile you start to say, Hey,
actually this is pretty good. Uh, you
know, this is not a crazy thing after all.
And he acquired case. Yes.
You know, the first time,
the first time I had
scotch whiskey, I, I, uh,
I didn't know what I thought about
it. And now I love whiskey. Right.
It's an acquired taste. So the first
time you drink something like that,
you think, you know?
Yes. They put resident,
they put pine resin in their white wine.
They chill it.
I should've brought you some.
Maybe I'll send you on an acquired taste.
What's not Ouzo Koolaid. It's delicious.
Just from the beginning. Yeah.
I just write out a job cold
and it's a sweet good. Yes,
yes, yes. We'll have to convince
anybody. Yes, that's right. That's right.
Somethings that's right.
Some things are just good right
out of the budget is good. Yes.
Koolaid is just good. Yeah. I mean, I
don't recommend you drink it all the time.
It's full of Shit. It's terrible for
you. But damn, this stuff, it's like,
it's like a, it's like fried
foods, you know? Yeah, sure. Yummy.
A lot of them. Yeah. French
fries. Yes. I mean, come on
man. Salt and catch up. Yeah,
I like that line. I like that. No, I'm uh,
I'm not sure about what I should mention,
but anyway,
I love Popeye's fried chicken. I do
as well. I love it so bad. It's awful.
And my wife, my wife is unlikely to
listen to this full podcast, so, or I'll,
I'll skip over this part so she
doesn't hear this part, but,
and my sister will be listening probably,
and so she will laugh when she gets to
this part because whenever I see about my
eyes, I just pull over and indulge
myself and then I terrible. Terrible.
The top eyes is good,
but you know what?
If you really want to indulge
and you like chicken. Yeah.
Roscoe's is [inaudible]. No, you
don't know. No, I don't know.
Chicken and waffles. Oh Dude. I tried
to go the chicken and waffle family.
We tried it.
Don't you make that face?
Tried to go there the other day with
my family on a Sunday, hour and a half.
Wait on the same plate. Sunday chicken
and walls course on the same plate.
What are you a communist? Yeah, man, it's,
it's La Syrup on them to
hell. Yeah. And butter. Yeah.
You mean the shooting is put
it on there. Yes. It perfectly.
It's this damn delicious in my
mind. You're from another planet. I,
I make maple syrup.
I live in Vermont and I make Maple Syrup.
I tap my own trees and, wow. What a
freak I have. I have a, yeah, exactly.
Giving people a hard time for waffles
and chicken again. The colonel,
the colonel is a liar. He does
not have it. Get out of here.
It's not even the colonel.
The colonel is norm Macdonald's.
I saw it's not no.
The old one kernel.
It's normally very like promotion or
something. That is nonsense. Yeah.
But they do not,
oh my gosh.
I can waffle syrup goes on top of the
chicken that chicken and waffles and
chicken tastes like cat litter compared
to Roscoe's. Also sweet chick La.
He could try to get this
out of here. Uh, so, uh,
it's stuff can go fuck off Roscoe's
chicken and waffles and you get the Greens
to the Collard Greens. Collard Greens.
Yeah, that's fine. Damn good. That's fine.
But that's a waste of maple syrup.
Take it from a man who makes it up to
put her sweet chick is good. I'm sure.
Sweet. It's not this place. I get it.
I love it. I've been there. It's great.
Roscoe's. Okay, I'll have a look fuck off.
Cause the reason why there's an hour
and a half wait on a Sunday. Okay.
How long you in town for a just
a day babe. I'll be back though.
I'll be back in a couple of weeks
over there right after this show.
Maybe I'll go there for a little one on
Gower. Okay. Oh man, it's good. All right.
Maybe I'll try that.
It's so good.
And it's also one of those places has
been there forever. We used to get it.
I found out about it from 19 Oh
1994 when I was doing news radio.
95 ish I guess. Been in La since
you left the Massachusetts? No,
I went to New York for a couple
of years then I moved down here,
moved down here in [inaudible] 94 okay,
so you've been here a long time and
when I was on news radio they got it for
like you could order lunch
and someone ordered Roscoe,
she became addicted and I was like,
what is this like waffles?
And it was just like you waffles and
chicken. There it looks. That's, that's,
that doesn't look as good as
it looks when you're there.
When you're there and you smell
it, it's damn good. Sorry,
I'm doing a Roscoe's commercial
here with an incredible, I'm a fan.
It's an incredible
combination of items based,
so it's so good.
And afterwards you better have nothing
to do, man, into a food coma son.
Anyway. Um, how do we get to that? W W
I know, try you. Maple Syrup stories,
different countries, different countries
in opening your mind. So you resident.
Yeah.
So you are counteracting my resin flavored
white wine with these maple syrup,
syrup and gas chicken.